era il lontano 2015 quando l'ultimo
episodio di guglielmo tell andava in
onda sul canale youtube di wilbur cinque
anni dopo è arrivato il momento di
riprendere quell'antica ancestrale
tradizione di cui l hotel sul canale e
ho anche un effetto musicale dovuto il
mio telefono perché finalmente dopo
tantissimo tempo ho pensato di
riproporre guglielmo tell che ho sempre
pensato come un format di classe b di
serie b perché perché avevo il mio primo
canale del quale facevo le parodie gli
sketch tutte queste cose qui con le
parrucche e quindi nel secondo potevo un
pochino più liberarmi essere meno non ha
mai funzionato questa cosa perché
comunque anche nel secondo canale non è
che abbia dato il meglio di me l'idea
del guglielmo tell
mi è sempre piaciuta e ho pensato di
riproporla cinque anni dopo
rullo di tamburi vi presento guglielmo
tell prima puntata versione 2.0 33 2.0
2.0
guglielmo tell per chi non lo conoscesse
era un tipo di format che avevo in
questo mio secondo canale nel quale
chiedevo alle persone cosa fare
arrivarono un sacco di consigli di
qualsiasi tipo ho dei ricordi
meravigliosi legati a questo format e
quindi vediamo un pochino cinque anni
dopo con l'avvento di instagram che cosa
mi è stato suggerito perché ho fatto una
domanda proprio in un tempo le facevo su
twitter credo ma iniziamo lisa punto
torellini scrive prova a fare un origami
difficile carta forbici il cigno è
l'unica nella sua complessa che so fare
e da piccolo mi divertivo a farlo
da piccolo mi divertivo a farlo con
pezzi di carta minuscoli per il figlio
più piccolo che è fatto quanto era
grande quanto il tool open e pensa male
è quello più grande quanto il pene di
gianmarco minchia minuscola
qui si faceva la fila non riesce il
pancino zia riportano in orfanotrofio
chi è da queste le cose che so fare da
sempre vola giulia caso 06 mi dice cerca
nelle carte il gomito non si può fare ma
tutti alta non si può fare lo posso fare
con un effetto speciale conosciuto
qualcuno rosse lena 24 mi scrive impara
a memoria il testo della macarena o
dalle ato cuerpo allegria macarena che
tu cuerpo e spa darle allegria è cosa
buona
balla to cuerpo allegria macarena e
macarena macarena tiene un ovvio che se
la ma che se lama e appelli dovi torino
che la jura de bandera e il mucciaccio
seme t.hawk ondoso amico cioè si mette
con due millimetri che gela il giura di
no non ce la faccio allegria macarena
tra parentesi o my blue mi scrive sono
qua 487 mila 900 29 anni che ti segue
non mi e mai risposto io che ti adoro
così tanto come blu che adoro anch'io
ed ecco qui che ti rispondo dopo così
tanti anni che non sapeva vissuto manco
i tizi casspi ness
mi scrive visto che non guardi ma i tuoi
stessi video beh fallo wow
allora devo andare tipo indietrissimo
sul canale dipendenza da wii ed effetti
collaterali
come giorno dopo giorno ai videogiochi
stanno lentamente prendendo il
sopravvento su tutti noi però non ci
siano è la fine del mondo
ai ragazzi non avete fatto lascia era
simpatico uno scritto guglielmo tell
[Risate]
elisa mi ghini scrive scoreggia
pitta bianchi mi scrive file invece box
challenge quindi devo fare così forse
con l'altro ma non è facile ma non c'è
un box quando tu sei gianmarco allora io
vado a chiamare intanto 113 ma così
entra direttamente al primo piano ma sai
che forse sei stato il più bravo tu non
mi sono visto io ti ho visto francesca
carchedi scrive aprì un vecchio
guglielmo tell
metti un minuto a caso e rifai quello
che stavi facendo dai francesi può
arrivare questo così vantare piccolo
gianluigi non si vede
ho beccato questo mette una canzone dall
ipod infilati le cuffie e nelle narici
apri la bocca diventerai un
amplificatore vivente o no io col cavolo
che le infilerò forza no no no non meno
terribile cioè per me sì mi sta dentro
nel cervello così esiste la bocca ha
detto un ragazzo perché chi conosce
questo canale nat atto di ravenna si
sente di più ovvero harris non fatemi
sapere se qualcuno di voi è riconosciuto
questo pezzo è un pezzo che è legato
alla mia infanzia al mio cuore e anche a
youtube
scusate non so perché l'ho lanciato così
ma non di una pulizia pazzesca adesso
veronica punto pozzato scrive piastra i
capelli ma non i miei errico 6 qui
questa è una cosa che avevamo già
promesso in passato avevo promesso
migliaia di adesioni e ricoh è giusto è
giusto e corretto
io so pieno dei nodi e va bene
tranquillo c'è questa si chiama spazzola
tu non ti spazzolino non farmi male
mamma mia ma la bellezza e sofferenza
prova farei da solo tieni questo brucia
perfetto però solo perché si trovi
sbagli alla come viene sì il fumo è
normale dopo ti voglio fare una treccia
ma tipo vichingo o siti si sembra
vecchio adesso ti faccio una pettinatura
emo pettinatura tara bassa pettinatura
galadriel barra the witcher e infine
pettinatura rapunzel
massimo ma gran macrina mi scrive
trovati un lavoro sollevatore di
polemiche inutili
non c'è preso il posto gli omofobi sono
attratti dai gay tria a me tutti gli
omofobi e buzz proprio di nicotera mi
scrive togli il caffè da dove ten i
piatti finalmente ancora stalla ed
elicottero brava che vorrei fare noi
però andiamo con ripresi un
aspirapolvere ma ma di respirare questo
qui è partito andiamo andiamo era così
semplice non sono bisogni non è le belle
cappella e butta credo forse non averla
mai fatto nella palude nulla no
ringraziamo nei commenti tutti quanti
fede nicolò pero e l'elicottero se ti va
bene livello di pulizia
faccelo sapere altrimenti ritorniamo ma
guarda pinkett e non farei il prossimo
caffè tra due secondi di ricotta
comunque nell'offerta rimane sempre
valida sofia gardens mi scrive conclude
il video tipo la parte del pollice in su
per il in farfallino farfalle avallo
forava graf atc e fer per ava le ferie
di fist of o questo o di chi de feo fo
le fette fefè of un po li qui i film
super mettete un pollice in su se mi
piaceva questo video iscrivetevi a
questo canale e soprattutto ci vediamo
al prossimo vivide vedo forti ciao